yeah you know when to welcome to this
video playing who would that shitty
mujer I'm okay that's a new opponent
another play doh so we've got an English
opening with Bishop c5 okay interesting
so I'm going to play d4 and dispersion
gain some additional space yo ok so its
chief okay here or not I like to gain
the space so let's go with the g4 Bishop
g5 that can be a pretty annoying pin
right let's go for that so this idea
seems to be to unpin in radical fashion
with the g5 but that is pretty radical
so what am I going to play here I mean
f4 is possible it just looks incredibly
loose the smooth
I don't see why it should not work so
let's let's do it i mean maybe it is too
loose and there is some tactic but now
the diagonal is 71 but this is an
extremely annoying pin really
so right after stuttering camera again
that's very strange I had this this
problem before what is this doing here
just put this to each one from it's a
bit strange here this is this stuttering
camera I wonder do I have some hard
drive full or anything no a friend of
mine suggested that it could be a hard
drive is Hubert I absolutely I run some
programs but no the program's didn't
find anything at all okay so okay Bishop
Bishop wow wow that looks a bit awkward
[Music]
you what is he doing now after Queen d2
is he giving up some material or night
some nights you fall or something okay
yeah well I can just take with the
nighty night there's nothing wrong with
that okay rookie to I can also take III
now that looks wrong well let's take in
and so is he now giving up the exchange
of what is he doing hmm this is possible
yeah but I thought I thought just the
night move is good I mean I'm
threatening to take and play 95 which is
completely devastating all night to g3
that also is possible let's go here
maybe you can just take the exchange on
g3 I have to watch the time that camera
is irritating me that stuttering camera
I have to I have to somehow get rid of
this it's completely rotating me
yeah this isn't clear at all
I don't quite believe in blacks play of
it I'm not sure if it is objectively
good for me so now I'm attacking with
everything but it's not overly obvious
how how I'm breaking through him yeah
but first of all he has to find a good
spot for the Queen and there are also
some other ideas I mean this Bishop is
not really having many squares I mean if
you place Queenie evade or something I
can play queen bee three I don't know
where this Bishop is going to go there
is no good square I'm also checking p7
this one ok and here is g5 amongst
others but queen bee three is also
certainly an idea the bishop doesn't
have squares and be serving a saying of
course so Bishop default and say I can
take b7
I think you probably played hookie aid
or something trying to find some counter
play against my open King check those
bishops are pretty nice
[Music]
this is too much on age 6 let's this is
better and now I just I just need to
need my queen involved if I do this
however where is he going with this
screen he doesn't have any squares here
it's all covered pretty neat okay so
check I'll just take stuff Queen has to
come somebody here
thalia morning check there is an old
maid that's funny at least I don't see a
maid even Bishop g7 that's not leading
to a maid really weird check in elevated
challenge and or some other challenge
let's do this okay and it wasn't
particularly convincing I think the
position was certainly unclear hello I
don't know that that position here with
this pin is definitely tricky for black
to play but this f4 is the initial
computer reaction is positive but
f5 while the data did not think about f5
is a very good strategic move though
simply shutting out this bishop and then
the engine just place like this and
continues yeah this is fantastic while
you just this is just completely
consolidating and try to play with the
huge advantage in space now that's
pretty good EW druke d3 Wow d 3 yeah of
course all those ideas are totally shut
down with f5 it's very strong Gharib d3
was better and Here I am well I'm kind
of skeptical about the engine after two
or three seconds I mean I think it can
easily jump to something else if you
give it a more time that the position is
fairly a fairly sharp Kim it likes my
position but really tough the same this
this Queen you ate and look a 2 e 1 not
giving up material all together yeah why
not yeah of course and it's a smooth
it's a bit stranger that I did not
consider that it just keeps all the
advantages and here white is better I
wasn't sure I had the feeling that it
should be better or so because next
position is just not coordinated well in
fact it is a complete win with queen bee
three it's just overload yeah this
attacked this attacked his chatting up
material now no yeah that was a very
risky set up here for her
and especially here after yeah I should
go by five that's a very strong that I
didn't look at it all ok guys thanks for
watching